it is a little weird now that I'm doing
it in front of people literally alone
like this hi BA and I'm Andrew and today
we swap beans nuts
don't worry we're you know a very good
taste in here I guess I don't need to
worry about it no you should be very
wary three two one I brought Raimondo
which is a cookie this is super old
school snack I don't know when they
started like that's long as I remember
usually grandma ha ha ha what's the
flavor life so it's like ping crepe and
it's crunchy bye covered awaits
chocolate and it said accidental crepe
excellent crepe was good thank you
what I see it's baking chocolate chips
semi-sweet chocolate morsels usually
used for baking and I think it's a great
snack because it's a smaller bite you
know it's basically like a mini
chocolate kiss you can eat a lot of them
or just a couple it's usually a really
good chocolate like I think this is very
good chocolate it's just like a nice
taste of chocolate whenever you want it
okay so let's swap sure
I know exactly what this tastes like
well I know this is good I have had it
before
good does it has to be semi-sweet think
semi-sweet is a good balance oh this
one's actually kind of coated in like a
chocolate cream I didn't really realize
that from the outside hmm it's good
right
I don't know if you can see that but
it's almost like a KitKat but even
lighter this was good I want to try mine
yeah
does it bring you back to childhood yeah
it's a grandma's house
yeah memory old grandma I think I like
mine better that's okay okay I like mine
better
mine will complicate a dog what are you
talking about more complicated this is a
straight up chocolate yeah
really is slop my snack then yes nut
because I want I want well I like this
okay
make sure you know what's important well
I won't sound but oh you already saw us
next next snack you swap this out you
swap okay sweetie - I feel like yes
snack dates there's no surprise I was
showing somebody else my snacks and they
said that it was old man's I was gonna
say you're like you are old my trap
thing young man's body it'll be an easy
transition to the old man body bag what
kind of gorgeous isn't it decoupage in
Japanese I think it's called the coupon
they call it sumo in the grocery store
it's it because look like a sumo
wrestler I think so it's kind of like a
bloated Orange
yeah it always has this like little
mound up there so that was like the sumo
wrestlers head
this is his body and in general I tend
to buy fruit every Saturday and then
that's a common snack I have right now
this is the hot fruit to have what's
your name can you guess just looking at
this picture
honey pretzels or garlic hotdogs me bye
so this called cutting tall I'm also
like old lady this is kind of like
grandma's favorite food okay yeah so we
both like oh oh oh mine taste you know
yeah this is like fried dough and now
it's soaked do it zero is this like nuts
yeah it's he knows okay so it's like a
sweet cheese doodle let's swap done
okay sure oh this one has an easy-open
yeah this doesn't have an easy-open what
you're talking about is the prepackaged
food made in nature that's true it's
like eco-friendly that word smells good
it smells like honey roasted nuts like a
can of beer nuts what do I call this
cutting thought that ain't though yeah
mm-hmm
this is really very much like a honey
roasted nut doodle I like this this is
juicy
sometime it's like citrusy potato on
this but this it's like has a nice kick
sweet and sour and he says a lot exactly
you want for orange this would be an
excellent pairing with beer I like it a
lot now I might swap you for this you're
a big dude really mm-hmm
ready 1 2 3 I like how yours it's what
you see is what you can be yeah this is
probably the most regular of all my
snacks but this one also has a slight
modification which is this hot sauce I
like this this is actually very accurate
to what I do
mm-hmm in my regular snacking practice
at home yeah where I often have tortilla
chips but no salsa mm-hmm and so I end
up just sitting and eating single chips
where I like drop hot sauce on each one
and eat it
this is the most lazy my snacking deaths
I think I eat this one
not when I'm hungry but when I'm bored
and I want
it tastes exciting in my mouth she's
happy she eats your mouth it's lovely
for you
even you're not hungry but you want to
eat something that is amazing
I got lovely mouth often but these
particular tortillas are very thick
which I like
this style of cookie it's my favorite so
it's kind of like battery cookie and rum
raisin
do you like Ravens I do I do too yeah
well people like raisins okay you ready
yeah sure the cookie does look very
buttery and I like that kind of like
shortbread mm-hmm do you have any like
these fractions I would just do like one
drop of hot sauce in it I usually like
start with a drop and then I'll ramp up
until it's just like unbearably spicy
it's this particular hot sauce - that's
habanero yeah so just like drunk pick up
yeah I guess I usually do it where the
hot sauce hits my tongue first I like
I'll sit over yeah okay I don't know why
whole chimp
everything in Japan is packaged to the
maximum number of layers Oh interesting
why do you think that why is it rattling
the raisins are miniature and dried
inside hmm smells good though oh my god
you're losing all the races I'm tasting
the butter part it's close to what in
Koryo feeling is like but a little more
buttery and it's got the kind of dried
raisins that raisin cereal has Oh kind
of like mm-hmm I bet this would be great
dipped into milk maybe you don't see a
lot of raising desserts in America why
do you think people don't like raisins I
think it's usually when it's in
something and they think it's gonna be
chocolate no but it turns out to be a
raisin oh yeah those happened to cook
these a lot I get the disappointment but
I think raisins are good and do an
important job
no York yeah let's try
oh it is a little weird now that I'm
doing it in front of people merely alone
I hate this so we are not gonna swap no
I'm keeping mine okay
let me take it I like it too okay final
snack
I know snack it feels like both of us
got ya big ready three two one the bread
and peanut butter and a pickles
exactly I'm gonna make for you a peanut
butter and pickle sandwich but people I
don't know imagine the flavor how do you
feel that pickles in general I like
pickles
yeah yeah together they make something
even more wonderful okay I don't say I'm
excited very interested so this is mochi
mmm
when I say mochi maybe like you guys
think it's mochi ice cream it's the most
popular when I came oh gee like I
immediately think this kind of mochi we
made a mochi from scratch was very soft
but we air dryer and it's become very
hard it's like a salt oh my god yeah
he's like so you could just put this in
the shower of a hotel they're like okay
when you heat it up again it will become
softer okay and since it's dried outside
it's a little bit crunchy and the most
common way I think to emoji AIDS rap
with seaweed sugar and a soy sauce my
sandwich is actually best when the bread
is hot and toasted so maybe we'll toast
our ingredients together and then finish
them yeah that's fun okay all right
let's do it let's do it so we got open
toaster
I'm cutting my pickle into kind of like
a matchstick mine is getting to the
point where I would probably pull it out
for fear of burning oh wow it's moving
yeah the mochi laughs oh it's deflated
yeah I think mines are babies too oh yes
okay all right let's take it off all
right let's shred this off
let's assemble yes we've got a bunch of
peanut butter on a slice of Joe's I got
mochi and nori I'm actually gonna use
some of my hot sauce from earlier just
like a little here in there kinda action
and then I'm borrowing your chopsticks I
don't think I'll need all of these and
also some of these are maybe too big so
wow it's a lot of pickles yeah it's a
lot of pickles you know that's fine to
create into my soy sauce sugar are you
gonna just go for like those
cross-section of sugar on the soy sauce
okay and eat it I think my bread got a
little bit too toasted so it's a little
dry okay whoo Wow Wow like a marshmallow
that's good then I eat it yes mm-hmm
nice multi-ball it's very good mm-hmm
it's very surprising yeah because I've
only ever had mochi like a dessert yeah
which this is sweet but also with soy
sauce and the nori yeah it's very good
mochi is just made from rice this isn't
that different from eating like a rice
ball that's wrapped with seaweed and
this is just like a sweet and salty dip
yeah it's delicious
good I like it all right shall we do
this yeah okay this is actually not bad
yeah really mm-hmm
it's surprising very good so the way
that I kind of came around about
thinking about this was if you've ever
had a noodle dish that is has a peanut
sauce
yeah like Dandan noodle often the
topping is sliced cucumber so that's
kind of how
I rationalized the combination when you
eat pickle myself it's kind of like sour
and a little bit overwhelming peanut
butter fuckness kind of cuts this that
one is exactly yeah you're the person in
the office whose food taste I trust the
most
mmm and so many people have told me that
I'm crazy
peanut butter and pickle but now look
really likes it okay so what do you got
to say to that I don't think I would
like that it's good right good this is
like a savory s'more hmm so Andrew do
you slurps nuts I would happily swap
this this is this is an extra special
treat for me thank you
yeah I liked it a lot when I saw the
ingredients its own I saw the hates you
know yeah and I was like do I have to
eat it but I'm glad you did Wow biggest
compliment ever
yay that's good everything can be a
snack if you're not eating it at one of
the normal meal times I I would happily
swap snack with you I would swap snacks
with you ah she's right great discovery
oh oh yes
[Music]
you
[Music]